With speculation swirling that Avengers: Endgame
will find Earth's Mightiest Heroes traveling
through time, there's no telling who they
might encounter along the way.
No character from the Marvel Cinematic Universe
is off the table, so here's a look at some
dead MCU characters we might see in Avengers:
Endgame.
Of all the characters in the rich history
of the MCU, Brock Rumlow probably wouldn't
be voted Most Likely to Return.
But the villain known as Crossbones, who first
appeared in Captain America: The Winter Soldier
before dying in Captain America: Civil War,
seems to be making a comeback.
Frank Grillo, who plays Crossbones, revealed
on the podcast UFC Unfiltered that he is indeed
returning in a flashback in Avengers: Endgame.
Usually, Marvel keeps a tight lid on spoilers,
but as Grillo explained,
"I'm allowed to say whatever I want because
I'm never doing another Marvel movie."
Another character fans expect to appear in
Avengers: Endgame is Captain America's one
true love, Peggy Carter.
She's made a number of high profile appearances
in the MCU, from the 1940's through the present,
before passing away in Captain America: Civil
War.
But in 2017 star Hayley Atwell stoked rumors
of a return to the MCU by posting a photo
on social media that seemed to be from the
set of Avengers: Endgame.
Considering Marvel made a point of including
her in the first Endgame trailer, it seems
possible the fan theory that Cap and Peggy
will be reunited may actually come true.
One of the most talked about moments in Avengers:
Infinity War is the scene where Thanos communes
with the spirit of Gamora, the adopted daughter
he murdered earlier in the film.
It was later revealed that, as fans had guessed,
the reunion took place inside the Soul Stone,
which in the comics is known for storing the
spirits of dead heroes until they are ready
to be resurrected.
So it seems like there's a pretty fair bet
that before Endgame is over, Gamora will be
reborn, and considering the circumstances
surrounding her death, this is one father
daughter dance we don't want to miss.
Vision has already been brought back from
the dead once through the power of the time
stone, so we know it's possible.
Of course, he was then immediately killed
again, but as an artificial life form, even
if the Infinity Stones aren't involved it's
theoretically possible he could be rebuilt
by Shuri or Tony Stark.
One way or another, his love story with Scarlet
Witch deserves a happier ending.
Like Crossbones, Arnim Zola isn't an obvious
choice for resurrection.
But we know Marvel's filmmakers have been
trying to get him back into the picture, as
he almost appeared in Ant-Man's '80s flashback.
And there are two easy ways to get him in
the picture.
Firstly, in Winter Soldier we saw that he
had achieved digital immortality by uploading
his consciousness to an old computer system.
While that was destroyed, it would be super
easy to have backups.
More interesting, though, is the fact that
Zola was alive and active as a Hydra mole
inside SHIELD for several decades after World
War II.
That would make him a perfect villain to interact
with the Avengers if they go back in time,
and would also make it easy for his story
to intersect with a Peggy Carter appearance.
Connect those dots, Marvel!
Another character active in the past is Black
Panther's father, King T'Chaka.
Now that the Avengers know about Wakanda's
technological superiority, they could very
well contact T'Chaka for help in the past.
But we could also see Black Panther himself.
After all, we know that the monarchs of Wakanda
live on in a spiritual afterworld, ready to
guide those who come after.
Whether it's Shuri or M'baku, whoever takes
the throne of Wakanda after T'Challa's death
may very well visit him in the afterlife.
Even in death, the Black Panther protects
his people.
The Asgardian God of Mischief has already
spent so much of his time in the MCU dying
and coming back.
With all the times this greasy little possum
has faked out the audience, it's no surprise
that Thanos felt the need to declare that
Loki would get "no resurrections this time."
It also means we're not entirely ready to
believe him.
And he's not the only dead Asgardian who could
make a comeback.
Every single person in Thor's life is either
dead or missing.
Having Odin, or Heimdall, or the long lost
Sif return would finally give the god of Thunder
a little hope among all this loss.
Speaking of lost families, the members of
the Guardians of the Galaxy have been struggling
with their ghosts from day one.
"Everybody's got dead people!
That's no excuse to get everybody else dead
along the way!"
With most of the Guardians now dead themselves,
the stage could be set for some more reunions
in the afterlife of the Soul Stone.
Drax's wife and child, Peter's mom, Gamora's
real parents, they're all possibilities in
Endgame.
Perhaps the most important lost family in
the MCU, though, are Tony Stark's parents
Howard and Maria.
Tony's fraught relationship with Howard was
the focal point of Iron Man 2, and the circumstances
behind their death drove the plot of Captain
America: Civil War.
Considering many people expect Endgame to
be the final chapter in Tony's story, it would
be thematically appropriate and emotionally
satisfying if Tony and his parents were reunited.
Perhaps even more important, though, is the
fact that Howard Stark is a co-founder of
SHIELD, and thus the spiritual father of the
Avengers themselves.
Considering the credits for Endgame strongly
hint that some part of the film takes place
in the 1970's, it's very possible we may see
Howard and Tony Stark team up to defeat Thanos
together.
"What is and always will be my greatest creation
is you."
It got a little tough to keep track of everything
that was happening in Age of Ultron.
Remember Quicksilver?
Scarlet Witch's brother, Pietro Maximoff?
He ran really fast and died protecting Clint
Barton from a hail of bullets as Sokovia fell
from the sky.
It's easy to forget, though, since even his
sister hasn't mentioned him in the years since
his death.
But that doesn't mean he's been completely
forgotten.
With Disney's acquisition of Fox opening the
door to the addition of the X-Men and their
version of Quicksilver to the MCU, bringing
back Marvel's version of Quicksilver might
be an interesting and unexpected way to begin
that transition into the next phase of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe.
No matter what Marvel tells us, we all know
that not all of those deaths in the climax
of Infinity War were permanent.
Heck, Marvel has already announced films featuring
a number of dead characters, including Spider-Man:
Far from Home, which is slated to open less
than three months after Endgame.
It's not a question of if we'll see the return
of Spider-Man, Black Panther and Doctor Strange,
it's just a matter of how.
We can't wait to find out.